if you do something in a movie does that
make it legal
we're asking the question of was that
really necessary we can't judge but we
can definitely be concerned the passion
and dedication actors put in for their
roles can sometimes get out of hand
we're taking a look at the artists that
may have taken things a little too far
when it came time for role preparation
number one some of us would jump at the
opportunity to revisit our high school
days but for tom holland not so much
holland was cast as our beloved
spider-man and skyrocketed him to a-list
success but he wasn't all that
well-known before putting the outfit on
which gave marvel filmmakers a chance to
get him into some method acting they can
figure things out
that doesn't work tom became a secret
agent high schooler at the brooklyn high
school of science one that is definitely
fitting for his on-screen character but
his experience was unlike parker's it
was very boring although he thought of
his time at the school to be informative
and fun when bragging about his new role
number two oscar-winning performances by
lady gaga have been coming in by the
truckloads and house of gucci is just
another performance to add to the list
but what goes into her preparation for
the oscar gold pretty much living the
life of your character for a year and a
half i'm not saying that that's the way
to do it it's just how i do it she
developed her portrayal of the real life
reggiani by changing her whole lifestyle
eventually leading her to a very
difficult reality check after filming
had ended
number three no one can deny the mighty
sinister performance of michael b
jordan's killmonger in black panther we
felt his suffering and loneliness a
feeling we would have never experienced
if jordan slacked on the preparation to
capture killmonger's hatred and
isolation of the world he distanced
himself from people and lived a very
inside life but as a lot of the actors
we will mention have forgotten to
realize the consequences of
psychological stress on your body will
come back to haunt you i got a little
depressed it was tough for me for a
minute the end of filming dropped a
heavy load of loneliness and anger that
he couldn't seem to shake off it took a
long time for him to get over those
horrible feelings and a little help from
a therapist too
number four there's excitement brewing
around the release of the batman part of
it being that we get to see a new take
on the vigilante catwoman zoe kravitz
snagged the role and she didn't take it
easy on the preparation apart from all
the intense physical training she
endured she decided it was best to study
the styles of cats and lions fighting
this helped her understand how her
character would move in a fight and how
it would mesh with her martial arts
training we did some really interesting
floor work that incorporated different
kinds of martial arts and capoeira and a
kind of feline dance-like movement
number five when news hits of an actor's
transformation social media makes sure
it hits everywhere this was the case
from a behind the scenes photo of
benedict cumberbatch getting ripped for
doctor strange too maybe a little
unnecessary for his character given he
wears a very conservative robe and cape
but could this mean he's buffing up for
his evil variant from the trailer if not
he's probably gone too far in the
multiverse
number 6. we feel like tom holland is
going to disappear if he loses any more
weight but he's willing to do anything
for the role i wanted to make sure that
i did justice to all the people who were
suffering his role in cherry transformed
him from the teen superhero to a very
dark and gritty character fresh out of
war this role required a lot of
emotional and physical demand his
dedication brought him to the extreme
lengths of fasting and running in trash
bags number seven we're back with yet
another segment on intense weight loss
david harbor edition this has been a
tough year for uh
for jeans everywhere the red guardian
roll in black widow required heavy
physical transformation and within a
very short time frame to capture the
fallen hero image in his later years
harbor asked producers to move all of
his heavy build scenes to the very top
of the schedule making it less difficult
for him to take off 60 pounds for the
flashback scenes of his character which
they ended up filming last the severe
measure he took in losing the weight
quickly involved basically starving
himself the girlfriend was not too happy
about it either
number eight kumail nanjani went big on
his first superhero role in eternals as
far as preparing for it he watched a lot
of star-studded movies because his
character kingo had blended in on earth
as a bollywood megastar non-johnny chose
to emulate the qualities of superstars
will smith and tom cruise and create a
fresh take of the two's best attributes
number nine sometimes when our favorite
actors push the boundaries too far it
negatively affects everyone around them
that was almost the case for robert
pattinson when he went to disgusting
lengths of staying in character for the
lighthouse it's absolutely ridiculous
that the whole thing doing something as
silly as spinning around before takes
and putting rocks in his shoes started
making him a little nauseous and his
only co-star william defoe was not
having it having to experience working
with an extreme method actor can prove
to be troublesome but being thrown up on
was not on defoe's itinerary his poor
character was supposed to sleep on
pattinson even while he began gagging
number 10 tom became an international
success before he was cast in the
upcoming film uncharted and he didn't
waste time in preparing for the coveted
role of bartender turned action
adventurer nathan drake he already had a
ton of action and stun experience under
his belt but bartending was not his
strong suit so holland thought it would
be a great idea to take on a bartending
job at an upscale restaurant it really
was only for a couple scenes but the
real question is how did no one
recognize him
number 11. another anticipated film
coming out soon is marvel's morbius but
all we get for now is a powerful trailer
showing jared leto's body
transformations knowing how leto can
take things a little too far with this
method we hope he didn't take it too far
with this drastic transformation number
12 like we said leto can take things a
little too far and this one was probably
the most detrimental to his health for
his role as mark chapman in the film
chapter 27 he prepared himself to gain a
lot of weight quickly he achieved his
goal but it came with very disastrous
consequences because of the quick weight
gain he developed gout towards the end
of filming it was so painful for him
that the crew had to push him around in
a wheelchair between takes
number 13 shia labeouf went to drastic
measures for his role in fury as soon as
he took the job he ran off to join the
national guard to become a chaplain you
got to start doing stuff so you believe
it and that was just some of the stuff
that i felt was needed changing his
whole lifestyle and taking on a whole
new title for a role is a little much to
say the least not to mention he pulled
out a tooth and knifed his face up we
can't even explain half the things slip
off does so we'll just leave it at that
number 14 these actors in their
disastrous diets yikes and now we fall
upon ashton kutcher's role prep for jobs
it was important for him to take care of
his representation so he changed his
diet a very unusual diet that steve jobs
himself followed in real life but eating
nothing but the same fruits and plants
is enough to make anyone get sick if
they're not used to it unfortunately for
kutcher it gave him pancreatitis twice
during the duration of filming
number 15 last but certainly not least
we get another robert pattinson gone too
far moment this was for his role in good
time but it certainly wasn't a good time
for him in preparing locking himself in
a basement and refusing to take showers
seems like the usual extreme method
actors go through but the poor costume
department had to pay for it this time
he wore his costumes from the film to
get a better feel for the character and
he never washed them isn't it a little
strange seeing the lengths actors and
actresses go through to prepare for
roles of course you have to do your
research and prepare a little but
endangering your own body and lifestyle
may go a bit too far did you think any
of these actors or actresses went a
little too far or not really at all
leave a comment below